Hi I'm Tucker.
>> And I'm Dev.
>> Welcome to this mini course,
Manipulating Financial Data in Python.
Our goal is to give you
a quick introduction to
the skills you'll need to work
with financial data in Python.
Now, some people complain
about our choice of Python for
financial applications.
>> I don't agree with those people.
Python allows you to quickly
prototype algorithms
while also providing
computational speed.
It has a number of features.
Firstly, it has strong
scientific libraries.
Second, it is strongly maintained.
It is also fast if you can stick to
metrics notation because lower levels
are returned in C.
>> Some other potential languages
that might have made sense for
this course include R and MATLAB.
Which are themselves also great
languages for financial data.
But we've chosen Python and
we'll be using this book Python for
Finance in the course.
Look for
readings assigned in the course outline.